i mean why are you still smoking what
does daddy feel about it
daddy potentially doesn't know anything
about it that's my one of my favorite
qualities about yes like a truly loving
person
[Music]
patrick
hi
how's your film
good did you avoid the temptation to be
obvious
i think so that's all you can hope for
isn't it
[Music]
what did you feel when anthony died
i was uh
very concerned for you
no not what i thought would what did you
feel
you might never felt through you
i just wanted to ask you a few questions
about anthony
make a memorial for him
no one's giving a direction no well me
i'm the director you want the camera
here um
maybe here make actually no seriously
here sounds fairly typical for an art
school but come and work on the farm for
a bit
i think he is contributing to cinema
you're forcing me to have a tantrum yeah
he's contributing
in the real life this is the three days
before your character dies is this quite
difficult for you they're obviously
dealing with this unimaginable loss
i'm struggling to recognize whether i'm
missing anthony as person he was or
whether i'm missing that intimacy
you have to learn how to take critics
what does it make you feel and have to
find a way to make things work none of
us have any idea what's going on
you have too much faith in me i always
say this you're doubting yourself when i
won't leave you i won't let you do it
what what has changed i don't want to
show life as it plays out i want to show
life as i imagine it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you